les invitamos al referendo sobre la
adhesión a la federación rusa les pido
que vengan a votar Felices vacaciones
para ustedes
fue el último día de votación para estos
residentes de una de las cuatro regiones
ucranianas parcialmente ocupadas por
Moscú que votó Para apoyar o rechazar su
elección a Rusia junto a ejército
regiones que representan más del 15% del
territorio ucraniano a pesar de ser
consideradas como votaciones ilegales
por el derecho internacional algunos
presidentes consideran que formar parte
de Rusia les llevará la paz
hemos venido aquí porque queremos que
todo se termine queremos que llegue la
paz y que todo el mundo deje de luchar
entre sí Rusia está decidida anexionar
estos territorios e incluso ha vuelto a
plantear la amenaza nuclear para el
presidente se trata de proteger estas
poblaciones
en todos estos territorios en los que se
celebra este referéndum está en primera
línea en el centro de atención de
nuestra sociedad y de todo el país
Ucrania hay una gran mayoría de la
comunidad internacional aseguraron que
no reconocerán los resultados la Unión
Europea incluso anunció estar preparando
nuevas canciones económicas e
individuales contra Rusia
habrá consecuencias para todas las
personas que participan en el referéndum
ilegal ilegítimo
pero no comentaremos sobre la
preparación de la lista de sanciones se
requiere la unanimidad de los 7 para la
adopción de nuevas sanciones la Unión
Europea ya adoptó seis grupos de
sanciones contra Moscú incluyendo la
suspensión de sus compras de Carbón y
petróleo